gosh what's up everybody how you doing
and welcome to round table with the
stream team good time now and this is
where we sit and we talk to content
creators about their amazing journeys
and what they do and what they are how
they're you know how they are where they
are today and today we have krispies
here from wicked games he is one of the
three individuals like I was saying last
week that we're going to be taking time
to interview it is gonna be we had dumb
Papa Tom last week we're getting crispy
this week next week we're getting you
know dr. Bob who's not really a doctor
and we're gonna deep dive into that next
week cuz I can't wait to ask him what is
going on because I'm confused as
anything away actually is a doctor of
but we'll get to that next week so
crispy thank you for taking the time to
come and hang out how are you doing
what's going on man of course I mean
thanks happening but I I appreciate
they're looking forward to it I've been
I haven't seen you in a while so it's
it's kind of nice to see a face even if
it's just virtually yes but I asked
myself I've been good man it's just kind
of getting by with what's going on so
just enjoy my life from the indoors at
the moment but no complaints here yes
the quarantine life is we all live
that's right man it's I did something
else let me tell you thank up for video
games to get me through this let me tell
you oh man if if I haven't been training
for this for four years I think I might
have been gone crazy oh yeah I mean
we've been training for this our whole
lives I mean I don't go out as it is
right well you go have to get beer you
go to the bars yeah I mean that's a
little treat well thank you very much
for coming and stop it and I can't wait
to you know talk to you about everything
um thanks Oh so we are we are one one
panelists down omj you had to take care
of some personal stuff i he hit me up
last minute it was like Peter I can't
make it so unfortunately he is not here
with us but we have miss l-boogie Oh -
oh eight what is going on how are you
doing I'm doing well I'm pretty good
yeah feeling really good I found some
sleep aids yes melatonin gummies yeah
slang I was like I didn't know and now
I'm a total believer so if not not to uh
not to be a drug dealer right now
right um my wife she is part of this
thing called neora and one of the things
they have are these melatonin gummies we
call them sleepy shoes and they they
knock her out yeah and it's so good and
they just have them sent to her how like
sent to her house since our house yeah
every month so she just got a pop one in
she pops one in around nine o'clock
around 9:30 she's like I gotta try those
bad boys out if you want some tell me
and I got the ones but they're pretty
good tonight it's funny cuz I my kid was
like when we went and got him there was
some four kids and she was like oh I
want to try them too best yeah it's like
your basketball shooting them from there
their energy shoes so they do the total
opposite it's one of those in the
morning she takes the sleepy one at
night it's great it's great that they're
all-natural you know so you're like so
anyway yes well thank you very much for
being able to make it today though yeah
and everyone knows me I am snell dopey
you know don't never type and pronounce
my name so yeah
it's me and I'm here hanging out playing
lots of video games
have you been oh that's irregular for
you that's the oh my god because we're
inside it's like we're so restricted on
what's going on yeah we so my my little
I'm taking I'm taking a wicked game
thing my weekend thing was running cat 5
cables and coax cables with my dad so we
could fix this Internet problem so we
don't drop internet connections anymore
I have to worry about it and my stream
has been popping is in the words of MJ
so it's been it's been great so a couple
days so I don't know if it's like at all
everyone being inside type thing but my
internet has been awful so so I know I
don't even believe me I am I'm dumb when
it comes to that I guess know that I
have Xfinity ok Xfinity is not a full
fiber connection so you're probably in
the same boat as I am like the way that
that works is um you have a like a node
which is like a group of people in an
area so all these people will connect to
this one node so if one person needs
more bandwidth the node will go ok this
person will get it and will give it to
them and then they'll be like oh this
person needs more Internet and then give
it to them so if you have like a bunch
of people that are an Xfinity in your
area they're just gonna like zap you so
you know those grey boxes that are like
on the corners yeah those are those so
like your internet runs to those I can
hear you yeah but anyways what happens
is all the internet runs there and a lot
of times all that - there is fiber but
then when it comes to your house it's
coaxial let's crap them I mean toss and
I'll bandwidth give me a little right
yeah but yeah I always know it's around
9 o'clock because I have no party
ability and I still have Verizon and I'm
supposed to have fiber but I know it's
like around 9 p.m. it just sucks oh I
got myself in my living room the other
night like my internet completely went
out out of no way I was like loading
into a match of Valor and it was like
the first round and before you know it
the thing just shuts down so I go oh and
I handle it
and I go back into the kitchen to get
like a beer like an hour later and I
caught myself staring at my router like
like kind of like hey I'm like what am i
doing I'm a grown man
yeah lunging at I wrote it to tell
myself like you know this is what's
going on stop trying to fix it you know
there's really like nothing I can do
because I do IT stuff so I'm like trying
to go through all the steps but it's not
gonna do anything because it's the main
you know I'm an apartment building so
it's everybody is sharing this huge
cable so I put another call in to
optimal online so there will be out this
Saturday nice so they're coming out
Saturday so I can sit down with this
dude and be like listen here's 20 bucks
this is what's wrong I know this is
what's wrong those guys down the street
probably having some you know backdoor
internet website that I cannot name
because TOS conditions that are ya
what's sucking about bandwidth between
this time and this time so please fix
this the worst part coming from an IT
background like both yourselves I mean
when you call and just like I need help
with this because I've tried everything
it's not work it's like we'll have you
tried unplugging it and plugging it back
in I know what I'm doing do they have me
on a list they were like oh no like you
have to speak to like managers all the
time I'm like cool that sounds good for
me because that bypasses all the stupid
people I have to talk to like you're not
you are not offending me at all sir I'm
very happy I don't have to talk to you
dumbasses it's a better point me
straight great better for you better for
me when win put your manager on the
phone wait with whatever Internet
Service Providers at work I call I
called them up but I'm like I'm like I'm
like hey Chris how you do it like before
he even says his name I recognized his
voice how's the family how's the kid
what's wrong this is what's going this
is the link this is the guy I already
called your technician because I have
his personal cell phone number he's
gonna be here tomorrow
just put the ticket at four please put
the ticket please
so what about ul huh what were you
playing this weekend so I've been
playing a lot of SIA beef still I don't
know what it is like I want to play the
game again although I tried to play
arena and it said this my 20 minutes to
get in a match I don't know if that's
normal or not like yeah the weekend or
like they were having trouble because
you know they just released like a new
update right with like a new content and
people trying to get on but it took
forever man yes because I don't know
anything let's see of these what is the
arena so it's like their battle royale
of swords so you come in and you got
four crews great and there's like ships
and there's also like an island where
you can loot stuff but the point is to
try to sink as many people as possible
before time runs out hmm okay okay so
there's lots of maneuvering going on I
mean like people were trying trick moves
you know you're able to like harpoon
people and grab onto this ship pull them
close to you like in their special
cannonballs so there's one that'll make
someone's anchor drop there's one that
will take all their stuff there's one
that'll make them start dancing like to
play in teams yeah
so there's like four crews oh yeah four
crews of four on galleons like it's
pretty crazy yeah I mean me personally
I'd never got into it but I'd know
people that loved it yeah yeah and I've
watched people stream it whatnot I have
a blast playing just for me it was just
never something I really could get into
I played it once I was like yeah maybe
I'll try again next week and next week
turned into three years yeah yeah no
like I totally get that it's not for
everyone at him like it was funny
because I'm a girl woman gaming on
Saturday someone is like we had a guest
and he was like chase money and he's
like see it feeds and I was like look I
want to hear it don't talk to me I don't
care that you don't like the game I'm
enjoying myself leave me alone I see I
don't I don't have a problem with the
game it's like I
the time to play it and I have so many
things I want to play and I guess I need
to focus on so much stuff to you know
make sure mainstream communities happy
yeah and then times like the times that
I'm not playing I am with my wife I with
my family that's what I do
so it's like I have to have this fine
line of what is going on and what's
happening happy balance oh yeah well
that's why I like I stream like at seven
eight o'clock at night because that'll
give me time next or it's kind of
decompress a little time kiddo
we just found monopoly speed which I
didn't know was a thing you can play in
ten minutes yep I mean those games
usually take a day and a half I will buy
that yeah yeah that in Apex Call of Duty
of course that's what wins this weekend
that was awesome in there battle royale
and then I think oh i played Madden it
was on ESPN this weekend too because
they said that even with MLB and I heard
in a couple other games that they've
been playing with major league people
have been laying these games and they're
streaming it
yeah there's everyone and then like yeah
NHL is starting on May 5th they
representing like at least one person
from every 31 teams playing each other
that's the thing like at that point it's
like you need you know those guys that
are gamers yeah cuz there's always a
couple of gamers that are just lurking
well then also let you know how thirsty
everyone is for any type of major league
sports entertainment because most people
would not watch this but they are
because this is all you have you're
gonna watch video game do nothing when
people ask me they like PT you watch
sports I'm like eSports like no real
sports I'm like what's real sports like
you touch each other very quiet right
now because there are no real splits
like you said we've trained our whole
lives
I actually didn't play sports in high
school ah me too
that's like that was like my glory days
no washed up now it's crazy listen
listen my sport in middle school not
even high school was tennis okay that's
kind of badass though I like that that's
what I played with the short shorts
because it was still like I was so hot
it was horrible how many pictures that's
my mom she probably had some somewhere
yeah there was every game and they were
like I know my son's terrible at sports
but I'm here to support them but now
sucks I'm Way better than any of my
other family members in tennis so I
think she works out really really well
so it's good it's good but so so Chris
once you first tell us what you were
anything a plane for this weekend what's
going on probably Valerie non-stop but
you have to explain that game to what
are we going to that and then we'll go
into your background so yeah so this
weekend I mean I really hadn't been
playing much of anything besides Valerie
and animal crossing a little yin and
yang right there I mean two completely
opposite games but Valerie is like the
best way I could describe it's a it's a
mix of counter-strike and overwatch
counter-strike with the gunplay
overwatch with like the they call them
agents in balance but their abilities
you have a healer and there's like no
tanks or anything but everyone has their
own ability so you're able to kind of
build out comps from there and of course
you watch the pros and they are kind of
setting the guidelines of what's going
on comp eyes but right now valor instill
in closed beta so the only way to get it
is to get a drop from Riot Games on
Twitch and a lot of people have gotten
them they've given up so many at this
point but there's still people chomping
at the bit trying to get it
me personally I'm liking it I come from
a counter-strike background and like my
cup of tea is first person shooters
that's like really what drags me in and
I'm liking it it's it's super
competitive it's frustrating as hell my
desk is definitely not happy with me
with the amount of times that I've
punched
but it's it's good to have that kind of
competitive spirit back in a game
because I haven't had that since I
played csgo years ago can I say that
what I ended up making sure I ended up
doing I don't remember if it was with
Tom or not but I was talking about
throwing my mouse when I got it when I
get used to get pissed off when I was
younger I playing first-person shooters
I would literally like take a mouse and
just throw it where I broke two of them
and I'm like I got to stop doing this so
I'll get a wired mouse
well it wasn't wired mouse so yes so
what I ended up doing was I got like a
squishy ball so now well not now I don't
do it anymore but um my anger management
issues have not been they're better now
but I just take it I just used to take
the ball and squeeze it and then throw
it man so I ended up doing that a little
bit better than the most I mean I've
definitely had my fish you have broken
controllers and keyboards and mice I I'm
a little bit older now so now I just
take it out on the mousepad but I
definitely contemplate to get like the
little punching bag for the corner your
desk maybe that's a sign I should stop
playing competitive games but it's it's
it's like a drug I can't get enough of I
just have to keep playing it but like I
said that game it's it's my flavor of
the week at the moment I was telling
people forehand I was like my big thing
is I get super addicted to a game first
show up here at a time and then I get
sick of it I'm like Finbar kilometers
from the fairly oddparents like I just
forget what I was doing I'm like I never
liked the game in the first place even
if I loved it but this game I can see
myself playing it definitely more a lot
of companies are one out of doing
big-time tournaments and stuff it's kind
of projected to be the next big FPS
eSport there's people leaving their
current teams from counter-strike and
joining new organizations and whatnot
it's a there's definitely a lot of
growing for it and then on the contrary
I've been playing a little Animal
Crossing my villages hate me because I
haven't seen him in a couple weeks so I
feel bad yesterday what did they say to
you when you logged in for the first
time when I log back in think it was a
guy named coach he's like a little
English Bulldog looking guy and I think
he just said oh you still live here or
something like that but he was passed
you don't
yeah they like they email on you real
quick yeah
you see what Dave said and chat by the
way he said yo Tom look is a crook it's
a fact he is it's like real tag like
don't trust time you show up on the
island he's a guy thanks for joining
you'll me 50,000 Bendel's away dude I
haven't even put my sleeping bag down
yet he's like there is the matter of
your bill absolutely honestly he might
be the biggest villain in video game
history yeah that's pretty funny it's up
there and I will say this every podcast
this week well with all you guys one of
my favorite highlights is when you
screen to Tom Nook alright so I'm not
proud of it but I knew it was like the
perfect opportunity for content on our
social media so I was like alright
sometimes you have a one in a lifetime
chance that like it just everything
falls into the right place right time
and DOM and I have been going in on our
Twitter and like blogs and stuff at the
time saying how much we can't wait for
the game and how much Tom Nook sucks so
I saw Tom Nook well like one of the pool
little interns dressed up as Tom Nook
walking by me a grown man goes hey Bob
move out of the way for a second I
pulled my phone I'll go Tom you're a
crook I screamed at the top of my lungs
and make all the Nintendo head work as
heads like snap close the video that was
like I just walked away do I regret it
now what you needed to hear your
frustrations no yeah yeah you had
turnips in your bills I didn't do it
just for me I did it for everyone that
plays the game call me a hero if you
want but I do poppadom man's broke his
hell over there Island yeah alright so
I'm not dead that's Dom like the Bell
King he's the kids making millions of
dollars in bells I made like a measly
like 40k and profit on the stock market
and I thought I was like big Meech in
John's like oh well I made 10 million
bells yesterday I do it I get in but
I've worked as I have employees I had my
little sister getting my turnips on
Sundays selling them if I don't have
time and then just mailing me my cut and
I give her
little profit on top of it of employees
it's good you got that pyramid scheme
working already
yeah yeah so so now we could finally ask
you tell us about your background your
gaming and you know where you came from
and all that fun stuff
yeah I have a very diverse background I
would say when it comes to like work and
life and stuff like that do I did I
think I would be making like a podcast
or have a gaming blog probably some
piece of my mind I did at some point I
didn't realize the uptick in kind of
gaming content that what happened in
kind of this day and age but I was young
I was probably like 14 when I built my
first computer just off of youtube I was
like all right like I'm a nerd I wear
this proudly I love this so what do I
want to do for work I want to do IT so I
kind of went through my whole life with
like that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do IT and I did that for years and that
was when I had a job working with
poppadom Annie approached me one day is
like you know how to build websites
right I go yeah he goes you want to
build a website like you could be a part
of this blog that Rob and I try to build
him like yeah I'll definitely do that so
that was kind of where we made that
sound we built the website over a couple
months and I remember our first blog
that we put on there they were like me
personally they were trashed I come from
a background where like he's a very good
writer very articulate and everything
like that in me I was like I'm just
rying to find my footing I thought I was
just the behind-the-scenes guy fast
forward four years now we've been doing
it weekly we blog daily it's a kind of
the new norm and I'm lucky enough to
have a career where I work from home a
lot and I don't necessarily have to be
somewhere every day so when news breaks
you boys on the keyboard I'm like I like
I'm good for this which is why I'm kind
of our social guy as well because as you
guys know social media is all about
speed and creativity so you got to be
like on the ball when stuff breaks and
that's kind of how you build the
following from there gotcha gotcha Dave
thank you very much for stopping by
appreciate it get you sleep I know you
know nighttime life is up up your alley
so thanks again for stopping by my man
so yes you know not this is prior to
quarantine life thankfully that you were
able to
you know for you to be able to have this
social media side because I noticed over
over the course of time like your the
Twitter feed it mostly comes from you
mm-hmm so I kind of figured that out so
well like generally cuz like we're
talking before I want to get into the
good deep dive for wgg you guys all for
um you know in a couple of weeks but
like generally what would you say your
role is for the site and for the podcast
everything yes I would say my main role
is social I would definitely say that's
my main role but once again I am a
co-host on the podcast we've been doing
it for 177 episodes we have almost a
thousand blogs on the site probably like
a quarter of them come from me maybe a
third of them and then I think my strong
suit within wgg as a whole is the social
aspect of thing I've definitely spent a
lot of time trying to kind of perfect
how social media is supposed to be done
and I think I finally kind of broke
through and I know what works for me and
what works for our brands I personally
so I can speak kind of from a social
standpoint right kind of like best
practices that I've used within it I
think there has to be a voice behind the
name there's so many accounts where that
it's just like curated accounts where
you're posting viral clips and like
these little little blurbs that you know
we're gonna get tons of engagement you
clickbait this so people argue you could
do that but there's never really a face
behind it which is why I make it a point
to kind of post videos of myself doing
stupid [ __ ] sometimes it's like okay
like this is an actual person behind
this account and it's and it's work and
a big thing that I've seen as well is I
go by the 80/20 rule when it comes to
social media 80 percent is entertaining
20 percent is like plugging your own
stuff because you don't want to bog
people down on kind of going live new
blog help/support here look like no kind
of buffer in between of course it works
different with everyone this is what
I've just seen work with us so I'll do
like viral clips I'll do conversation
starters and then I'll beg oh yeah by
the way like it has a new episode of the
podcast so I try to sprinkle them both
and I've seen a lot of success but
that's why nice nice very cool yeah so
what what would you think is one of your
like number-one priorities for the
podcast and everything for you guys so
big priority to us and it always has
been and I'm not gonna steal Tom's
answer but I'm definitely gonna
highlight a consistency consistency is
huge I mean you have to be in the same
place same time people have to know
where to expect you one thing that I
think has kind of propelled us and
something that I find very important is
authenticity at the end of the day
people can find information anywhere on
the internet anywhere it's at your
fingertips you could type into your
phone you could type it into computer
and you're gonna find a billion blogs
owner you're gonna find a billion
YouTube videos on it but people want to
relate to the the Creator people want to
relate to what you're saying and kind of
how you think of it and even if they
don't agree with it you have to be able
to embrace debate you have to be there
and you have to have that conversation
back and forth and that's kind of how
you build that but I don't think we've
ever changed in the past four years that
we've done it we've had big-time guests
on we've had hometown buddies and we act
the same way every time we're just
friends were just normal people behind
them on today just chopping it up and I
think a lot of people like that and I
don't see that necessarily changing for
us any time soon if you want to throw
the bag at us and go you can't sway
anymore maybe I'll try no I'll
definitely try but like I'm still me
deep down and I just always try to be as
transparent and authentic as possible as
is Dom and Bob as I tell people all the
time if you're gonna throw like you know
the bag of cash at me I will I will take
it yeah tell me what you want me to do I
mean write off on my gold jetski into
the sunset never swear and again just
tell me so I said you started to do more
streaming now because of a lurin coming
out because I notice your that your
twitch page is kind of more active so
when you started to do the streaming and
stuff did you just start now or have you
been doing it over the course of time so
I would say recently is when I actually
started I've tried in the past but I
never really got my OBS settings right
so
was always lagging and it just was never
enjoyable and it wasn't really it wasn't
what I wanted to do just because I was
playing different I wasn't able to enjoy
the game which kind of reflected to
people that were watching it recently I
got my settings right and I found a game
that I genuinely liked so I dreamed for
like I shouldn't for like eight hours
one day when Valerie first came out and
that's more than I've ever streamed in
my life combined I mean that's it's
really not my thing though at the end of
the day I don't necessarily see myself
streaming for a full day's work it's
just something I can't do it's it's very
difficult and I've learned to gain a ton
of respect for people who do it for a
living it's just really not me will I do
it yeah absolutely I mean at the end of
the day we're trying to grow a brand and
whatever kind of I have to do to do that
I will everything we do is kind of like
siloed back to the the brand as a whole
so we could all kind of do our own thing
but at the end of the day I just get
sucked back up into the umbrella which
is wgg so um what would you say is for
like the streaming side of for what
you're going through like what do you
feel is the most important for people to
see and to deal with when it comes to
that I forgive to play games that you
enjoy I mean there's a lot of people
that stream things because they think
that's what other people want to see but
you want to stream games that you like
because if you're gonna be sitting there
for hours you don't want to be miserable
at the end of it if you're playing
something you don't enjoy or something's
happening that you don't enjoy it'll
project off of you and the people
watching you can see that like this this
guy's like watching paint dry
or like this guy's piss off and like I'm
just trying to relax and this guy's all
mad and yada yada so if you play
something you enjoy you can trim for a
long period of time and I mean don't
look at the don't look at the viewer
count I know it's difficult for a lot of
people and they say like oh don't don't
look at the view account it's
discouraging first of all it is I mean
just kind of call it what it is but at
the same time do it because you enjoy
doing it which kind of ties into playing
games that you like mm-hmm so what is
the first game that you can remember
playing first game I can remember
playing I want to say Spyro original
PlayStation the og PlayStation
I remember being super young and I had a
tendency when I was younger to sleep in
very late but when I started playing
spyro we had one PlayStation in the
house so it was either I got to it or my
older brother got to it and playing for
a while and he would never pass the
control he would never let me do
anything like that so I'm like all right
after older brother I'm the little
brother and it was just like when I was
over there like I'm on PlayStation are
you wait your turn so I know he is not
I'm I'm the tallest person in my family
yeah no I'm a big boy
I'm a big boy but I would say spire and
I would teach myself to kind of wake up
super early so I used to be up at like
4:30 5:00 a.m. and just like go right
into the living room and play spyro
forever and then I got a Playstation
it was a pretty much a Portable
PlayStation I wasn't the PSP but it was
a Portable PlayStation and you were able
to like plugging in on the car and what
not and I used to bring the PlayStation
with me everywhere and like even if it
was like a small ride like I like my dad
has like the red yellow and white kind
of outlive whatever it's called -
pulling the cables
yeah the component cables I'll just get
it right now sky yeah how's it going to
plug it right in just play a little
spiral yeah that game definitely six off
me that and then Crash Bandicoot those
are like young like young boy like I
love that and then I think I got into
like the online multiplayer world with
SOCOM Navy SEALs SOCOM that's a great
game it's pretty good game phenomenal
game pretty pretty good how about you do
you remember the first game you can
remember yeah I think this is the first
one I think I'm pretty consistent in
saying this one but duck hunt it's
probably the most standout ish game when
I was younger
besides like you know that's like mine I
remember playing in my room you know and
I was like an only child for most of my
life I don't think I've ever played duck
hunter to be honest with you okay I know
exactly what it is but I think I've ever
played it yeah no I love Decker and
shoot the dog right that's what I did
with my dad
orange again yeah well I dyed the
original silver ones flex a little
hotter Pete why go up my grandparents
bought us the original Nintendo right it
was it was like one of those gifts that
we got and we kind of looked at me my
brother we were like is this really
happening our grandparents got us this
my parents were like you're only allowed
to play them Friday nights Saturday half
a day Sunday that's it and they give us
and I was just like oh man but like they
were super strict with us and when they
were gone like we knew our parents like
he'd the card that my parents would take
the cartridges and hide them on us
mm-hmm so we had to go digging and
looking for him yeah I remember that so
much like if I was like I don't feel
good I can't go to school okay I just
wanted to stay home and play games my
mom well I'm taking the wires to work
with me and back okay yeah you could
take him trust me I know exactly where
they were hidden and I would go grab as
soon as she left oh man but that's that
was the first game you remember oh yeah
for sure
I don't think I remembered anything else
besides like regular Mario Super Mario
and blowing into the cartridges you know
Oh
did you ever have to like put it in and
then push it down just ever so much so
it would work my dumb ass would do that
yeah you have to try both ways it's not
working the monitor like the TVs what
are you doing the TV's flickering great
yeah I mean maybe I'll try to I'm
surprised like bok-bok aides probably do
right they probably have duck hunter
there still is that like a thing that
can still float around I'm definitely
never sure proactively look for that
yeah we will see trying different things
over here because apparently my headset
is not being appropriately working today
um so don't mind me if I'm
[Music]
so yes so now you you've been playing
Valerie like you were saying before um
would you say that that is like your
number one favorite game like of all
time or current well both oh it's
definitely not my favorite game of all
time no it's it like I said it's kind of
my my flavor of the week right now I
don't know how long I'll necessarily
been playing it for but I don't kind of
let that dull down enjoying it right now
and so if we have to talk about favorite
games of all time this is a game I got
laughed at left and right for because I
just cannot stop talking about it have
you guys ever played the game bully the
[ __ ] I want them to make another one so
[ __ ] bad I was so bummed when like
the lead developer a bully left Rockstar
house ago we're definitely not getting
out which was only a couple months ago
but I was heartbroken and that games
that game was so cool it was so
different at the time I'm a big rock
star guy I love stuff they put out I
mean if we're not talking about bully as
a favorite game I am a sucker for the
GTA franchise I meet you I will still
like they allow you to do this like this
is like okay I remember that used to
like pull you should just like drive up
stop the kind of like beep twice and I
didn't know where the cowardice not like
yeah I mean san andreas was unreal like
that so I was such a spot I had I love
the Vice City and even recently I kind
of put this as one of the best games of
all time GTA 5 that was one of the best
games of all time and kind of still
sells more than a lot of games to this
day you had three characters that you
can play you could have you had a six
story line that can go in multiple
directions it was really really cool I
look forward to every one of those that
they put out and I mean GTA 6 has been
the most talked about thing for the past
five years now I mean if it wasn't for
that a lot of news outlets wouldn't have
like clickbait articles to put out well
I see
left and right till this day like GTA 6
confirmed taking place in Boston taking
place in Miami like this is the logo
this leaf it's all like bull at this
point how much do you think the other
way
oh we have a couple more years a sex Oh
and literally just not again developed
like probably a couple weeks ago right
it's an early development as of like a
couple weeks ago it's really funny the
camera with that comes through the fire
um so so GT so you're saying the GTA is
probably your favorite game I would say
so
bully bullies bullies my favorite game
of all time that is like hands-down my
favorite game of all time but I mean the
GTA franchise as a whole
I shouldn't say as a whole I wasn't a
big fan of some of them but like San
Andreas and Vice City and GTA 5 those
kind of grouped up is like my favorite
games if I had to pick one out of there
I say g5
did you like the version of GTA right
now what do you mean like the the
multiplayer aspect uh yeah I I I love it
honestly so I am I loved watching GTA
role-playing I think it's one of the
funniest things in the world those
people are incredible at what they do
like they play a character and they
can't break character and it's I've
tried doing it and it's very difficult I
play with like a couple people that hang
around and my character was the hell was
his name like sean sean Fitzpatrick and
I was I I used to own an auto body shop
on the east coast and now I moved to LA
to be an uber driver and pursue my
career as an actor like that was my
storyline so if you got stopped on the
street so I was like oh what's your
story
well that's my story and like you grow
from there I think so I'm a big fan of
kind of weird GTA is gone because uptick
and role playing that's come out of it
it's it's huge like like runescape
role-playing used to be a huge thing and
like it finally came back to the light
with Grand Theft Auto which is really
cool
do you think that which is your like
your favorite like open-world
would you say because there's not many
people that I know that like enjoy GTA's
which is you seem to enjoy it so I have
to ask like for me like I'm not a huge
fan of GTA but I love the open world of
Assassin's Creed yeah like I love that
yeah assassin's creed was always kind of
up there for me I hate how I guess
monotonous it really got and repetitive
that it felt but when I was first
starting to play that game like the
fighting mechanics of it in the way that
you're able to jump off a roof into like
a hay bale I found it the coolest thing
in the world
and just like thinking back to like a
childhood when I first got it when the
assassin was literally able just like to
snap two blades out of like it his
long-sleeve like cloak whatever it is I
love that so I guess open world was wide
wise I would have to throw assassin's
Creed in there do i play it anymore
no but that's something where you say
like open-world game like I did the last
shoot they came out Odyssey and oh my
god I'm blanking on what the other ones
called
was a black flag no no no why I believe
I'm blanking on it it's the one from
Greece or the one from Rome those two we
talked about thank you thank you those
two they changed the combat so much on
it it actually makes me sad yeah because
like I loved how Assassin's Creed was
and then that change it made it feel
like it was more of a God of War mm-hmm
and I was like I don't want to play God
of War if we got a war to play got a war
but like that was one of those things
that I kind of had to deal with and got
through but mmm all at all
fingers crossed it was you know it's
still a pretty decent game yeah I mean
it's done it's done well like I said
it's just like it's something where I've
experienced it I like the storylines
that they throw in there like how you
get to explore different parts of the
world I mean I love what they do they
did about the whole like Notre Dame like
a Coliseum or whatever it's called the
Cathedral like burning down and they had
it built down to like the brick and they
help them rebuild like I love what the I
do like that because it's a very
detailed focused game I get that but I
don't really see myself paying full
price for it anymore but it just goes on
sale two weeks later every time yeah
Ubisoft yeah it's
same thing every time you buy a full
prize since I got it holiday season
Assassin's Creed the newest game is $25
well that was the thing like with the
the whole thing with the was called
which is the last game that came out for
them break point mmm like I knew I did
not like wildlands that's someone break
point came out I'm like I'm not picking
it up mmm it's gonna be a waste of money
for me not doing it and then everyone
was like oh this is terrible this is
just like the old one on sale so like
all my friends like we're picking it up
on sale we were waiting for this we knew
it was gonna happen happens every time
it happens with Ubisoft so much really
like if it's not the sales I mean
obviously shout out to Dave on this he
didn't tell me to say this but the only
other way I'm gonna try it because like
I don't want to pay full price for as if
it's on game pass that is the only time
I like try game out if I don't have to
really pay for it I'm happy to try gears
tactics I'll try it I mean I'll try
everything
I'm its life you know it's good right
now it's live right now that I can play
I there's there's very few games that I
get like about okay yeah I said that you
do that again that was good I'm creepy
so um all those tactical games like XCOM
I love them so that Gears tactics
XCOM XCOM what was the new one that just
came out the Chimera Squad like I want
to play well all of them like I'm like
I'm gonna get him and I'm gonna play him
and I I'm gonna be like that guy with
the red bloodshot eyes because I've been
playing games really too late but I have
to still go to work the next morning
but like because I want to play all
those and that's with game pass mm-hmm
and it is the it is one of the best
pricing for anything you can play see if
these still you can you know you can you
had what is GTA was there and then
that's leaving and then granddad's
coming I read that too going
Oh gta5 if it's not on there already
everything is already there yeah the
best the only gaming I like hands on the
P thing and like I feel like I'm always
like selling it for them but it
genuinely is itself it does I'm hoping
with this next generation they finally
figure out family sharing no more this
like your you have my hometown so I have
your home console I bet they would I I
hope that what I mean there's a bunch of
it was something you know back in 2013
so and then they pull back remember
after the whole DRM issue so I'm hoping
that this time we can get yeah I'm like
with a bunch of streaming kind of
services as a whole it's it's usually
like one or two good games and then like
a lot of fluff just know well these
games are on there you can try out this
but with game paths they throw
legitimate games on and there's like dis
these smaller games I think there's a
game called like the life of Pedro or
something like that
so fun is obsessed like I would have
never played that well we were at PAX
East that game was there and yeah and
that would not last year but the year
before saath was ready to take somebody
and throw them out of the way so he can
get to the sea it's a play it's fun it's
really fun yeah it was like but it has
no reason being that fun which is what I
love to stick that did I causes havoc if
I get it's like the way that you're able
to like shoot a frying pan off the
ground and then ricochet bullets off
that it's like so simple but so complex
it was so fun did you ever play one
finger death punch
I have not okay
you literally press one button and you
fight hordes of guys are attacking from
the left and the right and we played it
at PAX East was it 2019 and it was so
much fun it literally you just won dude
going back and forth doing karate moves
and then like eventually you'll meet
like a boss and then you like have to do
like a sequence of boobs and they have
to do sequence of moves and then at the
end though you'll see you're like you're
fighting it out and blocking back and
forth and
messes up the other person gets hit
that's cool so it's really really cool I
will talk yeah well we're definitely
gonna talk is that sounds right up my
alley nice and simplistic it is it's
it's one of those games you can play not
have to think about it it's good so um
you know you've been doing this the the
the podcast for the past couple of years
the the website for a couple years so
how how did your family feel when you
said that hey this is what I'm doing
with me growing up I was always someone
who tried to start these little ventures
whether it was like buying and reselling
textbooks on Craigslist or if it was
like just like a whole bunch of stuff I
guy I'm the type of person where like I
would call my friends but guys I think I
get the genius idea I think this is it I
once had an idea of like a cleaning
service that would come near hose after
you had a party and clean your house and
bring you breakfast it was called like
hangover helpers which is in retrospect
the terrible idea but like it was stuff
like that we're like how did kind of how
my mind was going so when I first
started then I will say was a kick-ass
name it's a good name another one I had
I'm just gonna throw this up now I think
ma Cuban stole it from me like a company
he invested so for me I want to do
cereal milk will you let your cereal
like soaked into milk and then you
strain it out so your milk is that
flavor because everyone knows the best
part of cereals the milk after am I
wrong I love them see there is um this
is gonna sound disgusting
there are blueberry Cheerios blue specks
fall off into the milk oh yeah so then
your blueberry flavor not my first rodeo
do you think but I guess as for kind of
the blog in the podcast they were just
like okay my good doing B let's see how
long this one lasts and we started it
and like a year went by and they were
like you still doing that like yeah
like how cool and then another year went
by oh you're still doing that
yeah okay and then fast-forward three
and a half four years later I think I
was asked this like a couple months ago
so call it four years later
I was at my family's house and I figured
it might have been my cousin she's like
remember that a podcast you were doing
it for that for a while was I guess
it'll do a baby bigger than ever right
now but it's like it's something where I
enjoy doing it so I'm outside person I'm
not gonna waste time if I don't like
doing something I won't do it but I
genuinely enjoy this I like joke around
with two of my best friends on a podcast
and put it out there make fools of us
I'll make people laugh they I'm so low I
like doing it so I'll continue to do it
but I would say ultimately they were
supportive of it and kind of steps that
we've taken in the process like when I
would throw like a number at them of
like downwards us I'm like no [ __ ] I
like people actually yes so yeah I'm
gonna talk about it also when we go to
when the rest you guys are on but one of
the coolest things was when we went to
the predator party and you and and Bob
ended up gonna get your passes to go in
and they were like you're not on the
list and then that woman was like oh
they were here every year you can let
that man just listen to him and I and I
was just like damn he's got clout yeah I
know them they're fine like come on is
good I kind of like that better first I
was like no [ __ ] like we're not when I
somehow on the list again yeah and then
like that happens right cool that was
worth it I like yeah yeah that was one
of the memorable moments I can remember
because after that we just we started
getting sloshy oh it's a blur I mean
free booze I mean oh well you have to
come next year you're coming next year
it's a blast yes I hope so
I was on the west coast yes but I could
go to e3 like every year no problem yeah
I mean I might be biased because I'm
from where pack sees happens but it's
like something I look forward to every
year like the convention itself is
tiring as hell don't get me wrong
especially if you they're covering stuff
as media
ten craters whatever you're running
around your days a pack and then at
night you have like parties that you get
to go to and if you're like me and
sometimes forget to drink water the next
day is a [ __ ] and you're like well I do
this myself but I saw this pack schedule
and blah blah blah you kind of have to
go through the motions but at the end of
the day it's a bit super fun it's great
to talk about because you meet some
awesome people prime example ready I
would have never met Pete so one of the
when I think it was the Saturday it was
Saturday we were we came up to lunch and
we were sitting at our table Laureate
lunch and Bob just comes down and just
plops that under his table and he's like
I'm exhausted I'm like like we're like
I'm just chillin like relax I'm like
we're the rest of the guys and I don't
know where I just see you go who's Bob
here like we had no idea you sitting
there in the corner dude I was blurry I
was so groggy from the night before you
know I'm just kind of doing my own thing
I probably had no idea you guys were
even in the room probably got a cup of
water and sat in the corner yeah woo Bob
had snacks a new hell yeah I'm hungry
yeah they the the chocolate he had so we
have someone that we've met kind of via
the podcast and everything from Scotland
and actually flew to Boston to go to pax
and he brought us all these Scottish
like candies and snacks and everything
like that so we just had our bags filled
with like Scottish snacks and that's
what Bobbie had those little they're
like mint chocolate Spears and they were
incredible they were so good
there's like 300 of them in the bag and
just couldn't stop in them yes yes um do
you have any questions
[Music]
I'm an open book are you I'm an open
book
he's like me he will literally it'll say
anything all right do you have kids
I do not have kids I am as single as
I've ever been in my life Oh
once you reference the question that you
were asked last week on the pot on the
podcast
well no I forgot long as I ask
Oh what games do you play with your
significant others sorry Chris that was
there like that ultimate I love that
secondhand at the end of it I was like
all right like if I if I had one if I
what would I do beside you Chris okay
wonderful I guess I'm out of this
conversation
but is what it is I mean I there's so
much on my I guess plate with trying to
grow what we have going on and just like
normal life and stuff but really kind of
proactively looking for I'm young I mean
I'm just going to do my own thing and
well I was gonna ask if you played with
you kids no I mean I played like little
cousins and stuff I played games with
them I mean they're my little cousin
just got a Nintendo switch for Christmas
and he loves our Super Smash so he's a
very quiet kid so it was like Christmas
last year I think and he out of nowhere
like I feel a little tug on the corner
my shirt I was like what's up he goes
can you help me I'm like yeah for sure
so I go over sit down play with them and
I ended up like winning some match that
he got to unlock I forget who it was but
he unlocks someone and he was pumped
because it was who we wanted to unmark
and before I know it kind of spiraled
into his dad being like Chris you want
to play me how like yeah sure like I
always do this we sat we sat in the
living room just talking about the new
him so like Bob I didn't know like you
were you'd like like video games in this
he's like it was like dude if you only
knew he was like I'm such a geek I love
it alright so kind of like open that but
my little cousin loves super smash did
you ever feel the I'm sorry I can
remember let's go say did you ever feel
the need to just um give the Smackdown
so yeah yeah I'm not letting them win no
way it's like you gotta teach them I
promise you're not gonna win every game
that's kind of how I was brought up if I
played one-on-one against my dad in the
driver
you wouldn't take it easy on me and I
kind of like it helps you get better I
mean we're in the day and age now of
like participation trophies I'm like as
long as you try and saw like that I'm
not letting my family do that like no
I'm going full speed in the game like
grant dev it's like if it's like a baby
baby that doesn't know what they're
doing like I'll kind of take it easy and
then I'll smack him at the end like I'll
make him think they have a chance but I
don't hold back what we went to we went
to a party for my my wife's cousins and
one of their kids was not getting off
the computer downstairs and the mother
looked at me and said Pete we know you
we all know you're very good at video
games you might have to go down there
and beat them to get them up to come
upstairs so if this doesn't work you're
gonna have to go down there I'm like
okay
right I feel the same way like they need
to feel what it is what defeat feels
like a victory isn't as sweet unless you
know what defeat as Curtis Jackson aka
50-cent one said sunshine wouldn't be so
good if it wasn't for rain hey gotta
teach him that at a young age was gonna
say though what's your like your biggest
disappointment of the generation the
game like what game is your biggest
disappointment like you were so right
to play it any he played it and you're
like there's one thing that comes to
mind for sure because it was the first
time battle royale got introduced to
Call of Duty it was black out for black
ops for I believe yeah and when that
game came out in beta it was so fun I
was like I'm playing with all my buddies
and this is so different it's a whole
different feel to a br instead of
playing fortnight this is great which I
do not like for tonight just kind of put
that in there but I was playing now is
great I can't wait for this to come out
and then the game actually came out and
it was broken
like completely broken and just not
enjoyable to play at all and that's a
game I literally game mode I'll
literally talk about till this day that
had so much potential but I'm so glad
that was
own kind of filled those shoes I'm
walking was on the hackers and whatnot
in the game hitting as of next week yeah
and they don't let you turn that [ __ ]
off
no it's the only way to do that is to
kind of you have to disable
cross-platform but it sucks for me no
they won't let you play battle right
unless you have that enabled so yeah
they give you the option to take that
off for multiplayer but if you want to
play war zone it has to be on oh I don't
know that all right well can that wind
is it all right well I take that back
then but um I I I'm enjoying war zone
and like I was saying come Mike I think
it's may know probably like April 30th
or like May 5th or something they're
putting out another update for and the
game's gonna be pushing 190 gigs on
console that's a giant ass at a giant
game but like some of these people's
consoles are only what 500 gigs yeah you
need something I mean that's I mean
because I feel like you're either you're
either the type of player that plays
that one game every year right or you're
the type of player that you play a lot
of games so you're gonna have an
external so if that's your one game
you're so good but the problem is is
that most people aren't gonna understand
the concept of getting an external or
knowing how to like swap their hard
drive or anything like the PlayStation
were you gonna open that [ __ ] up and put
in a new hard drive like you literally
plug USB stick in this thing and that's
it oh that's good that's okay but like
well I thought it was you had to
actually pull the thing apart
nah that's PlayStation Xbox plugging in
the USB smart you're good to go
I love the facial expression because
it's like you almost want to dropkick a
PlayStation this is so stupid
like I went on to read it and they're
like oh yeah you know you're gonna need
these like hardware all these like tools
and [ __ ] and I'm like are you kidding me
like you really want me to put in a new
hard drive that's all so it's like the
simplicity of it right just want to kind
of plug and play and go I do want to
sprinkle in one
disappointment Kingdom Hearts 3 I was
very disappointed with Kingdom Hearts 3
cuz that game is a huge spot my hunt and
playing that i strictly played it for
nostalgia purposes it just felt so flat
for me I just really wasn't into it
maybe just because all you press is a
yeah it was it was not difficult at all
there's really no challenge to it I like
seeing like the different worlds I put
you in like Toy Story was sick yeah
frozen was actually really cool and just
from me I was like it's the same thing
over and over I still finished it I was
like it kind of that's a last game I
played on console and my xbox Xbox is
still collecting dust like right I
actually undid my Xbox never played
anyway only a PC player I I mainly PC it
I mean I mainly PC that guy had my xbox
on my desk and I plead I play Division
one on it and then I was like alright
what am I gonna do now
Division two came out I played that for
a little bit and I was like why do I
have this year I don't even play it
anymore so I just took it off my desk
it was literally collecting dust and
causing problems I just have a PC in
mine
do you play VR VR games so I have I have
a bad taste in my mouth with with VR
because the first time I tried it it was
in Montreal at Dreamhack yeah it was
after a night of partying and it was it
was Rick and Morty or something like
that yeah I was hungover and I put the
viago goes on and - this was through the
roof where I am you gonna play oh my god
I was I was hurting I was like I
genuinely think I have to throw up but I
mean when I try it again yeah I
definitely would but I'm not really
gonna rush out of the door pick up and
oculus or whatever had said that I can
play on yeah but I mean I wouldn't
completely sweep it under the rug I
definitely want to play beats a but I
feel like that games really cool can't
you can't play it on PlayStation
PlayStation doesn't allow you to put
custom songs plus I think for the money
I would buy just a quest because I have
both PlayStation and the quest
and for basically the same amount of
money as when the psvr was you know
first coming out you can get a quest you
have way better graphics
that's the wireless one everything's in
the headset so you don't have to be
attached to a computer or anything
you're good to go and you can download
custom songs so we download whatever the
hell we want
that's actually pretty sweet I'm gonna
have to give that a go at some point
yeah I've seen some people playing songs
like doing the beat saver songs mm-hmm
and all I can say to myself is my arms
would break like I don't know he
wouldn't do you wouldn't be good
doing like crazy flaying arms like my
kid is really good at it and it's
because she knows like motions like with
her hands so like her hands like barely
move but she's like hitting all the
boxes so you have to find that groove
comes with experience yeah you're gonna
play Wii Sports on you a bowling now I
could just sit down on the couches buddy
thank you same thing in my family what
come on let's play I'm like yeah but
spin on the wall it's great even have
you played baseball get velocity on the
ball by just snapping your residence
excellent I got one quick question last
question for you if FL is good what was
your favorite console hmm I would have
to say PlayStation 2 and that is just
because that was when I was really
ramping up my my video game life that's
where I actually realized that I
genuinely enjoyed playing video games in
that they had on there where we're sick
I mean other than PlayStation 2 strictly
for games that were exclusive to it if
anything sticks out from a social
standpoint which is kind of like
Backstreet Boys was in sync what I'm
about to say but Xbox 360 for a social
aspect of it I remember playing like the
original call of duty modern warfare
with my buddies and we serve run from
school and jump into private matches
together and play literally until 4:00
in the morning 5:00 in the morning I
wasn't even allowed choice okay I'm
going to bed and like I would have it
all the way turned down like hiding
playing it but it was from a social
standpoint I would say 360 but if it
ever came down to I had to pick I would
have to go with ps2 I've said this story
before and I'm pretty sure she started
before but um what I had to get my
PlayStation 2 and it is one of my
favorite consoles I had I was I was
working I got one of the first 2000 off
the truck if you look at the serial
number it's like eighteen seven
something I thought I would never get
rid of it just because of the serial
number alone but I was working and I got
a phone call on my cell phone I pick it
up on Michael Owen hello this is
GameStop we have your playstation 2 here
you have to be here within the next hour
to pick it up because if you don't were
giving it to the next person on the list
I'm like I'm working I can't get there
and they're like well that's what's
going on I'm like hold on one second I
was like I'm calling my parents so I was
like all right all set I'm like I'll
send my parents be there shortly
I hung up the phone called my parents
I'm like mom do you mind come and pick
this thing up and they're like okay sure
where is it I'm like all right said you
know the mall blah blah blah and then
the cool I was like the only thing is
you need have the receipt and they're
like alright well where's the receipt
I'm like I have their seed on me at work
and they're like okay we'll come pick it
up so thankfully it was around the block
so they come around the block grandma
receipt they go all the way to the store
and they go to the store and they buy it
and they take it and they put it in a
blah a black garbage bag like a
contractor bag and they like hold on a
second they're like why and they're like
oh we got to have you someone I escort
you you guys are gonna walk around them
all together for about a half hour and
then after that you guys can leave the
mall and the security guard will escort
you to your car and then you can leave
and oh my what did this kid freak yeah
and what ended up happening was is that
people were getting mugged when they
left the mall because the the consul's
were in such high demand and they were
selling so high like on like you know
like the back of the truck people were
getting mugged outside their
Playstations were getting taken so they
had to end up getting us
my guards tell of a story yeah it's it's
it's pretty crazy but it's like one of
those things I was just like my thanks
mom and dad for doing that for me
putting yourselves in harm's way for my
playstation 2 for my playstation 2 thank
you god yes
you just have to say that you're old
because my playstation 2 was a Christmas
gift like I was still young if you
didn't get that part
I also elbow too kid in the face when I
was on the line waiting for Final
Fantasy 10 because he tried to cut me in
line and I had to get the game and get
to class so I'm standing there online
right and some kid was like he's like oh
I'm so excited I'm so excited I was like
I'm like how old are you and he's like
I'm 14 I was like okay cool kid I'm
sitting there and it was like it was one
guy in front of me and then me and I was
there it was like 9 o'clock in the
morning at Gamestop I'm sitting there
I'm sitting there and this kid tried to
surpass me I was like I'm like hey I'm
like I'm online I'm like you gotta wait
I'm so excited I'm like I really don't
care I'm like I gotta get my game and I
gotta go to class so I'm like you you're
gonna have to wait and the father was
standing there and the kid tried to walk
past I just straight up like think I got
knocked him square in the head Oh
deserved it and he looked at the father
and the father's like he said you should
wait I was like yeah
love that and in all circles but act you
can't let the kids win yep so anyway so
um just just to wrap things up normally
we ask all the guests one final question
I'm not asking it for a reason because
I'll ask all you guys know you guys are
all together so but um why don't we you
tell everybody where you know where they
can find you on your socials and all
that fun stuff yeah so like you said at
the beginning I'm crispy I'm one thirds
of the founding fathers at wicked good
gaming you can find us on twitter at
wicked good games in every other social
media at wicked good gaming we're
starting to ramp up on YouTube as well
so youtube.com slash wicked good gaming
and the name of the podcast which I
might be a little biased but I'm pretty
convinced it's the best gaming podcast
on the internet besides the eye emotes
but you can find it it's not another
gaming podcast we're on all major
podcast platforms it's a
only a brush a breath of fresh air we
have a different voice within the
industry so I definitely think it's cool
to check out even if you're not an
ultimate quote-unquote gamer you can
find some humor in it for sure
excellent excellent and I'm happy that
you were able to spend some time come
down talk to us and hang out for a
little bit so I greatly appreciate you
for taking that climb out of course
thank you for having me thank you thank
you and L why don't you tell everybody
where they can find you MLB geo 208
mixer Tuesday through Friday 7 p.m. to
10:00 p.m. and I am here on Mondays and
then on Saturday mornings I'm on broham
again a podcast on YouTube with the
lovely ladies and yeah come take a
listen that's heated conversations going
on now that we're getting other people
to come guest yes yes if you listen to
the last week's podcast there was listen
oh I was there I listened when when my
wife was working I have to put my
headset on and there was a couple of
very good conversations so oh and Chris
did you tell them what time your podcast
is on Thursdays I did not so we live
shooting the podcasts on Twitch Thank
You Pete
we love shooting the podcasts on on
Twitch at 9:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time on Thursdays it's twitch.tv slash
wicked gaming and then the podcast goes
live on all those streaming platforms
Friday morning I think it's at like 5:00
a.m. on your Friday commute so remember
not another game podcasts Wow woman oh
my god I always forget that I always
call it W Jeanne Moos
my wife came over and gave me a face and
she totally threw me off so I'm sorry
groan when we gaming podcast there we go
so make sure you guys check those things
out as for me I am snail dough also
known as Pete I'm stream on Twitch 5
days a week 7 to 10
except for Mondays where I am here if
you're wondering how to spell my name it
is SN al why do just go check check me
out on Twitter discord all that fun
stuff
and this is the round table with the
stream team if you want to send an email
to one of one of our guests that are
coming on the show please email us at
roundtables stream team at gmail.com
please make sure you are following this
on a table stream so that you can end up
seeing what's going on who our next
guests are which is gonna be Bob next
week and you know and all that fun stuff
and when things are gonna be happening
and great things so thank you very much
for hanging out with us today make sure
you guys go hang out with the iron Lords
podcast Sundays at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time check out our website
which is Lords of gaming dotnet for more
gaming news also the week of your gaming
podcast guys so make sure you guys are
checking us all out because we be pretty
much the only websites you ever need to
go to if you ever need any gaming
information just so it's just I'm a
little biased but that's what I do and
remember to ever want to dream big and
keep gaming and we will see everyone
next week bye everybody and thank you
very much